He wants the personification of the
evil dictator clad in his familiar khaki
uniform men's cap and chomping on a cigar.
He ruled with an iron fist
over his island nation.
He took on the United States and brought
the world to the brink of nuclear
holocaust,
shifting his attention to his own country.
He decimated the economy,
creating a communistic dictatorship that
forced the people to revere him even as
he ruined their lives.
In this episode of Biographics,
we take a closer look at
the life of Fidel Castro.
Del Castro was born on August the 13th
1926 and the small farming village of
monogamous in northern rnt and Cuba.
His father and Heller caster you Gus had
emigrated from Spain in 1898 and picks
up work as a brick layer and the
railroad worker before starting his own
business selling lemonade
to field workers.
From this humble start,
he built a small sugarcane embark and
praising 26,000 acres and 300 work
families.
And how's the first wife Maria go?
I gave birth to two children and then
either died or simply walked out on the
family.
Unhealth soon.
Took up with his young,
made leaner Roos Gonzalez who bore him.
Three children and Yella
of Amman and Fidel.
The couple were married
shortly after Fidel is birth.
They were a relatively wealthy family
who lived in a deletion style two story
house in the country still.
They did live a decidedly country
lifestyle with chickens and pigs wandering
through the house.
Fidel was named after a local
politician with his name,
meaning faithful.
He did have his father's temperaments,
which meant he was prone
to violence outbursts.
His sister recalls that if he was playing
baseball and just team we're losing.
He would simply gather up the
equipments and walk off the fields.
Close friends and future novelist Gabriel
Garcia Marquez recalled that Fidel was
the worst loser that did have a
mask when he reached school age.
Fidel was sent to study and Santiago,
the second largest city in
Cuba for the first two years.
He stayed with his godparents
and was homeschooled by them.
After that,
he was enrolled at the Maris
Lasalle school along with
brothers Ramond and Raul.
Fidel soon gained a
reputation as a troublemaker.
I was a bit of a bullied when
he was in the fourth grade.
Fidel's father received a letter stating
that his three boys with the biggest
bullies in the entire school and how was
furious and pulled the boys out of the
school.
This enraged with Al who
threatened to burn the house down.
He ended up being sent to a more
demanding Jesuit school in Havana with his
father threatening to cut off his
allowance if his grades dropped below a
certain level.
Fidel responses to this by
forging his school reports.
Carsguru proved to be a
decidedly average students,
but there was one area
in which he excelled.
He had a photographic memory of facts,
which hugely impressed
his fellow students.
They would call them,
do a page number from their tax books,
and he would recite the page
word for word in his team's.
Fidel began to develop his ability as
a public speaker and there's a debater.
After an initial rejection,
he gained acceptance into the
Allover Bernardo Literary Academy,
which was the literary
wing at the Jesuit School.
At first he was paralyzed by stage fright,
but he gradually became more relaxed
and more confidence in his presentations
and obviously a very of 1945 Fidel
entered law school at the University of
Havana.
At the time,
the university was a self governing body
which for bead the police or army from
setting foot on campus.
As a result,
it was a hotbed of clandestine activity
by gangsters and political agitators.
It was a very attractive environment
for the hot headed Castro.
Fidelis first foray,
NC political imagination was precipitated
by a rise in bus fares that had been
authorized by Cuban
precedents ram on growl.
Castro organized a protest
against the fair raisins,
led a march to the presidential palace.
The police beat the students with Fidel
himself receiving slight injuries.
He used this incident to his advantage
by going to the press and receiving some
sympathetic coverage.
At the time the Castro in
roles at the university,
there were two main gangster
groups who were vying for control,
the socialist revolutionary movements,
Msr,
and as the insurrection or
revolutionary union you,
Iowa,
there were frequent violent
clashes between these two groups.
Fidel quickly sized up the situation
and began to maneuver between the two
groups.
In December of 1946 there
was an assassination attempt
on a leading member of
the Uir and Castro was
fingered as the trigger man.
His that seem to motive here was that he
wants it to ingratiate himself with the
MSR leadership.
As it turns out,
it was the leader of Ui,
Emilio Troy,
who took Castro under his wing.
He gave Fidel the pistol,
which the young budding revolutionary
carries with them at all times throwing.
They'd been planning and invasion of the
Dominican Republic in conjunction with
a group of Dominican exiles in response
to the terrible conditions brought about
by the rule of Rafael Trujillo.
Task very quickly jumps on board and sales
without 12,000 fellow revolutionaries
to Kayak on fetus on July the 29th
1947 for two months they arms.
When's paramilitary training before
setting off for the Dominican mainlands.
Meanwhile,
three Ho had learned of the plans attack
and didn't even appeal to the United
States.
For Eight,
the revolutionary leaders got cold
feet and cools off the invasion.
Ams,
the embarrassed given army began rounding
up the ships and taking the would be
attack is into custody.
Castrate managed to evade custody by
jumping ship and swimming eight miles to
the shore.
In 1947 Castro visitors a new model
prison on the isle of Pines as part of his
legal studies,
my name or sons,
Havana,
he criticized the prison and it's
inhumane treatment of its inhabitants.
The following year,
he was part of a student
congress that traveled to Bogota,
Colombia.
On April the seventh the group maps
with the leader of the Liberal Party,
Jorge Gasten,
who looked likely to win
the upcoming election.
Two days later though,
Gaten was shot debt.
Bogota erupted in violence
and the students from Cuba,
we're caught in the middle of it.
Castro became actively involved
participating in the takeover of a police
station.
After three days,
the authorities restored order,
but not before some 3,500
people had been killed.
Gastro returns in Havana where he
became a follower of Senator Eddie.
He bus the main opponents
of president ground.
He was the founder of the Cubans.
People party.
Castro campaigned hard for hibiscus and
is unsuccessful bid for the presidency
in 1948 I'm still the
two men whenever close.
Keep us all.
Fidel as somewhat of an embarrassment
user has gangsta backgrounds and Fidel
only ever viewed the leader as an
obstacle to his own path to power.
In order to gain political respectability,
Castro cut off his association
with his gangster associates.
He gave speeches on campus denouncing
the two main gangs and naming names of
those who were responsible
for criminal activity.
This made him a target for both groups
and he was forced into hiding around this
time.
Fidel,
who was generally awkward
and shy around women,
and that's martyr Diaz Balart,
the daughter of one of the
wealthiest man in Cuba.
The couple of fell in love and were
married in 1948 with motors father getting
them $10,000 for a three month
honeymoon in the United States.
Most of their time was spent in New
York where Fidel learn some English.
We're starting to Cuba.
The newlyweds moved into a hotel across
the street from a military camp in
Havana.
In September of 1949 matter gave birth
to a son who would become known as Fidel
Ito.
Having graduated from University of Fidel,
began a small law practice,
most of his title.
However,
we spent dabbling in politics on August
the 15th 1951 people's party leader at
he hit us,
was giving his usual Sunday radio address,
urging the people to stop accepting the
corruption of the government and take
action.
Even pulled out a pistol and
shot himself in the stomach.
The dramatic act was intended to rouse
the people keep us had spoken for too
long and to suicide attempt.
It's not broadcast for the next 11 days.
Keep us lay in a hospital
bed in terrible agony.
Oh,
his side.
The entire time was Fidel Castro.
When the leader died,
Castro was prominence as part of the
honor guard that stood outside the
university hall of Honor Work.
Give us in state how's the military
escorts prepared to lead the body through
the streets in a large procession,
Castro and treated the captain to divert
the root to the presidential palace.
Fidel was convinced that he could rouse
the people to overthrow the government,
but the army captain refused fairing.
There's an absolute bloodbath.
We didn't see him the following year.
Castro ran for a seat on
the Chamber of Deputies.
He managed to garner the support of the
majority of the People's Party members
and looked in line to when
the upcoming election.
However,
on March the 10th former presidents for
NCO Battista stage a military coup and
seized.
However,
he began rounding up his
political adversaries,
including members of the People's Party.
Fidel and his brother Raul
went into hiding the buddies
to queue diverted Castro
from what could have been the promising
diplomatic Korea in favor of becoming a
fully fledged revolutionary.
You gathered together
his own political group,
drawn from former party
members and followers from
his university days traveling
up and down the country,
put his oratorical lands,
propaganda skills to full
of facts off to 14 months.
He had a following of 12,000 people.
He ran his organization with
military precision and discipline.
Drinking alcohol was forbidden and
t imposed strict sexual standards.
He also organized his
forces at a cellular level.
We have members of each cell being
unaware of the existence of other cells.
By the middle of 1953 Castro had the
support base that he needed to stage his
own COO,
but he didn't have,
there were weapons or indeed
the money to buy them.
His solution was to attack a
military base and sees its weapons.
The base selectors was located at Mancado.
The attack,
however,
and was bungled from the start.
One of the 26 vehicles on route to the
base had a flat tire and other took a
wrong turn and did not arrive
until the attack was well underway.
When the remainder of the
vehicles arrive to the base,
they were surprised to find it heavily
fortified the military defenders,
so beach back the invaders with
eight of Castro's men being killed,
the remains or floods,
but over the next few days,
many of them were rounded
up by the authorities.
69 of them are eventually
tortured and put to death.
Castro himself was put on trial
before a military tribunal.
He used the opportunity to speak out
about the regime of Patista as the harsh
treatments of his fellow revolutionaries.
His courtroom defense statements
of history will absolve me,
which become probably his
most famous speech still.
He was convicted and sentenced to 15
years and imprisonments Castro and his
followers were sent to
the previous dimensions.
Isle of Pines Prison for doubt.
Muse does time that as who instilled a
supreme level of order and discipline and
as men,
the Castro rebels gains a reputation
for their good behavior and were given
great freedom.
Then on march the sixth 1954 Boeing's
public pressure President Battista
grounded amnesty to Castro and dismantle
the show of good faith from the
president's.
However,
did not stop Castro from
speaking out about the regime.
When two of his men were
beaten by Battista enforces
Fidel became increasingly
concerned for his own safety.
He would move houses every two to three
days and then just two months after
being released from prison,
he left Cuba from Mexico.
It was Casper.
Plan to build up and train a new wing of
his revolutionary army in Mexico and to
then return to join forces with those
already in Havana and a huge push to oust
the Patista regime is Mexican army began
as a group of about 60 cube and the
factors who lived in six small houses
under strict disciplinary conditions
imposed by Fidel.
It was during this period that
castering that Ernesto Che Guevara,
who would play a key role
in the coming revolution.
Castro launched his
revolution in late November,
1956 from the port of Tox
Pan on the Mexican coast.
It was planned to coincide with another
uprising organized by a rival antibodies
to group for Dell had bought a 60 foot
boat that was designed to take a maximum
of 25 passengers and deepen the old 82
of his men on board as it shoved its way
towards Cuba.
The boat was in constant
danger of capsizing.
The journey was so slow that the
five day trip took seven days,
meaning that they would miss the uprising
of the other group with the boats
beach at a place called purgatory points.
On December the second,
but by now,
but he's designy who had already put
down the fast rebellion had landed that
Castro was on his way and his,
that he had planes overhead ready to
strafe the invaders and bomb the area.
Only about a dozen men survived Castro
and Guevara or among them they again a
three day march through the forest,
constantly being hounded from
the ad by the Cuban air force.
They finally reached the Sierra Maestra
region where they settled with the local
villages and began to regroup.
Six weeks later,
Castro led 33 men on a gorilla raid
on a tiny army garrison in La Plata.
Two soldiers were killed and the rebels
stole off with a number of weapons.
A month after this attack,
gastric decided it was time to get
its propaganda machine in motion.
He sent one of his men to Havana to bring
a foreign journalist back to the camp.
The man chosen was from the New York
Times and Suny three part story had
appeared in the paper describing
the massive military buildup.
Castro was organizing
in the south of Cuba,
Castro support based group exponentially
with more and more disaffected Cubans
joining his rags.
In March of 1958 younger brother Raul
began to establish the second force out of
Oriente,
which soon grew in number.
Raul proved to be a highly
capable military commander
with his force capturing
and destroying many planes,
tanks and military vehicles.
In April for the cold calls upon the
people of Cuba to stage and nationwide
strike,
he believed that this would be the
start of his long plans uprising.
President Battista responded
by threatening to shoot
anyone who participated in
the strike.
As a result,
more than 140 people were
shot down in the street,
but this action only fueled Castro support
base and it's even more people stream
to support him with the tight now
decidedly turned in his favor.
Castro decided to move.
He sent Che Guevara and
another of his commanders,
Camilo [inaudible] goes on a
Westwood march towards Savannah.
Along with their rebel forces.
The government forces put up virtually
no resistance and the rebels were able to
take control.
One town after another on December the
31st 1958 with Castro's men closing in,
but he start resigned
and fled the country.
Three days later,
Castro arrived in Santiago
to a hero's welcome.
He gave a speech in
front of 200,000 people.
I was later Guevara or NCN for he goes,
marched into Havana and seized control
of the reins of power and just like that,
the Castro era had begun yet
transfer of power with amazingly orderly
Castro would want his mat and against
fluting or destroying property.
He had come to power on the backs of an
army of poor and illiterate peasants.
Now that he had gained power,
he would need to educate
men to help him govern.
He tries to a point,
his former professor,
Jose Miro Cardona as prime minister,
Renzi Manwell Aricia to be president.
He made himself supreme commander of
the armed forces behind the scenes.
However,
gastro put the organization in place to
ensure that he was the holder of overall
power in the weeks
following the revolution.
More than 500 Patista
officials were tried,
convicted,
and put to death.
That number would rise to
1,900 over the coming year.
Within seven months of seizing power,
Castro decided that he no longer had
any need for a public governments.
On July the 16th,
he announced that he was resigning his
position as on Monza because he could no
longer work with precedent.
[inaudible]
he had accused him of corruption.
Castro then disappeared
for a number of days.
Justice Fidel had intended the people
who rose up in protest and demanded that
the president must go the fries and
the president sought sanctuary in the
Venezuelan embassy before
escaping the country.
This allowed Castro to resent it in
triumph and to point himself as President
Castro.
Now in post totalitarian rule,
those who did not give
him that absolute support.
We're in danger of being seized and
put on trial or just simply shot.
Within a few short months,
all signs of resistance within Cuba,
including critical media,
had simply been removed.
Now,
Castro fixed his attention on
securing external security.
Uh,
focus was perched on increasing the
size and the strength of his army.
Six months soft up seizing power,
Castro and visited the United States where
he was greeted with enthusiasm by the
media as well as politicians and
the public behind the scenes.
However,
the Eisenhower governments was already
making plans for Castro's removal
in February of 1960 the Cuban leader
signs and agreements with the Russians by
which Cuban sugar would be
traded for military arms and oil.
This was at the height of the Cold War
and many of the oil refineries in Cuba
where American owns when the owners
refuse to process Soviet oil imports,
Castro sees their businesses.
The U s government responded by cutting
700,000 tons from the U S and your
purchase commitments intern at Castro
nationalized Usi and its agriculture and
industrial businesses.
Castro has move,
had a huge impact on the u s mafia,
which would cost about a hundred
million dollars worth of property in the
tourist industry alone.
During this period of nationalization,
more than 200 thousands
professional and upper costs,
citizens fled the country.
Relations between the United States and
Cuban government's became so strange
that in March of 1960 President Eisenhower
greenlit the training of a group of
Cuban exiles to stage an
invasion and seek control.
The bowl was picked up by President
Kennedy resulting in the disastrous Bay of
Pigs invasion,
gastric gusts of winds of the invasion,
and how does forces ready and waiting
with their lack of promised USS support.
The Cuban rebels cut to pieces on
December the first 1961 Castro when's on
national television and Declan's that
he was a Marxist Leninist and would be
until the day he died.
The Soviets took eight where he view of
their newly declared communist fellow
that the Americans responded immediately
imposing a total economic blockade from
Cuba.
This led to economic disaster with
massive food shortages resulting.
Finally,
the Soviet government
decided to embrace Castro.
They offered to station Soviet
missiles on the islands.
In Middle October,
1962 the American government's got
concrete evidence of the missile operation
leading to what became known
as the Cuban missile crisis.
Resident Kennedy placed a total military
blockade around Cuba and announced that
a military attack from Cuba on any nation
would be seen as a direct attack by
the Soviet Union on the United States.
Castro urged the Russians to make a
preemptive strike on the United States if
the Americans attacks the islands after
13 days during which the world was a
hair trigger away from
nuclear destruction,
the Russians backed down and
agreed to remove the missiles.
Castro was left completely out of the
negotiation process and he was not happy.
Soviet president's,
Nikita Khrushchev tries to placate him
by inviting Castro on a 40 day trip
through the Soviet Union.
During the trip,
Khrushchev offered to provide economic
aid to the struggling islands.
In 1965 the United States announced
that it was willing to take in Cuban
refugees.
This led to a mass exodus with a result
in huge loss of skills and manpower on
the island
with international situation and having
settled Castro satisfied [inaudible] on
making agricultural reforms
to improve the economy.
He wants to increase the sugar harvest
and set a target for national production.
In 1965 5.5 million tons increasing
to 10 million tons by 1970 these
expectations,
however,
they were totally unreasonable still,
he paused nearly all of the country's
economic resources into the sugar cane
industry,
leaving all other economic activity.
Baron,
the whole country,
including the elderly,
young children and military workers
were put to work in the fields in a
desperate quest to reach his targets.
Even Castro himself,
we sent two of cut cane
for four hours every day.
How's the rest of the Cuban economy?
It fell by 20 and 40% the sugar cane
project failed dismally to reach its
projected targets.
In 1970 Castro announced that the plant
had failed typical of his flat for the
dramatic.
He resigned his presidency.
The people demanded that he returned and
soon he was back in power and the sugar
crisis was behind him.
Throughout the 1970s Castro began
looking for ways to extend his influence
abroad.
He began involving himself
in revolutionary movements
and sending forces to
train and lead various
guerrilla operations.
It's supportive.
Civil wars in Angola and Somalia ate
up more of his countries with limited
resources.
During the early 1980s sugar prices and
production has increased significantly.
This allowed the Cuban economy to grow
at a rate of 24% but when the sugar price
slumped dramatically,
Cuba's international debt
ballooned to $6 billion.
At the same time,
it's still owed $19 billion
to the Soviet Union.
The Soviets trying to help by increasing
trade with the fall of the Soviet
Union.
In 1989 all the agreements fell apart.
The already week you've been
economy was severely restricted.
Strict to rationing was put in place.
The electricity supply became sporadic
and tractors were replaced with ox drawn
carts where there's country
on the brink of collapse.
In 1993 Castro Cubans to
start private businesses.
The following year,
he permitted foreign investors
to own given businesses as well.
If the economy which had declined
by 40% in the past three years,
finally began to grow.
By the 1990s castrate was an aging
isolators and largely depressed dictator.
The majority of his close associates
were either dead or had been exiled.
He still keeps up his habit of staying
in one place for any two or three nights,
so he was constantly being moved around
and a bulletproof Mercedes limousine
during this period of Castro's tight
grip on the country seems to loosen
slightly,
but then in March of 2003
he imposed a crackdown,
which Sol scores of journalists,
students,
and professional people arrested
us dissidents of the regime.
In July of 2006 the 80 year old Castro
underwent surgery for internal bleeding.
The following year he handed over the
presidential rents to his brother Raul.
From then Fidelis health grants
relate to Terrie right it.
The ends finally came on November the
26th of 2016 though the exact cause of his
death was never released.
The country was in mourning for nine days.
So I really hope you enjoyed
that episode of biographics.
If you did this,
a couple of things you could do right now.
One is hit that like button below.
Also,
if you want more stuff like this,
we put out brand new videos
every Monday and every Thursday,
so hit that subscribe button below and
subscribe button doesn't do what it used
to on Youtube.
If you actually want to get a
notification about these videos,
please do hit that bell button next to
the subscribe button and that'll send you
a notification every time,
every Monday and Thursday
when we put out a new video.
Also,
if you want to watch
something else right now,
stuff from the archive over
there on the rice and other ways.
Thank you for watching.